places like New York or California
Massachusetts Illinois these places
aren't as freeze it's made seem to some
of the people living there I'm Katherine
manga award for recent TV and today
we're speaking with the authors of a new
study called freedom in the 50 states so
why don't you start by just explaining
what you were hoping to capture in these
rankings what are you trying to
demonstrate or show well the unique
feature of our study is that it looks at
both personal and economic freedom so
everything from taxes labor regulations
on the economic side to homeschooling
regulations gun control marijuana laws
and the personal side so really what
we're trying to do is see which states
are best in economic and personal
freedom and let that be a tool for
citizens and residents of these states
to lobby their state governments or to
figure out that where they want to move
and because of America's federal system
states have a lot of ability to shape
all the policy and important ways that
affects people's daily lives so maybe
you can explain just very quickly what
your methodology was how do you capture
these somewhat ambiguous measures of
freedom particularly personal freedom
well overall freedom is composed 50%
economic freedom 50% personal freedoms
or paternalism if you will in terms of
the economic freedom side it's half of
that is regulatory policy half of that
is fiscal policy now of course any of
these types of indices there's going to
be a normative element to how you come
up with this but what we try to do is is
capture those policies and weight them
highest on those that affected the most
people involved important constitutional
rights and that you know we thought were
intrinsically important to being free so
who are the five big winners what are
the free estates so the New Hampshire
comes for a South Dakota right behind
and then Indiana Idaho and you remember
5th Missouri I think
so maybe I'm just a kind of cosmopolitan
snob but those don't sound like states
that we traditionally think of as people
flocking to them to live there so how to
explain this this sort of tension
between people's desire to be free or
the sort of attractiveness of these free
states and the fact that most of the
country's population doesn't look that
well well actually one of the
interesting findings of our study is
that there is a substantial number of
people who are moving to the freer
states and that are exiting the states
that are less free and so there's a
robot robust correlation between states
that are free in the economic and
personal realm and in migration so
people are moving to these places now I
think part of your question though is
about well there's lots of folks a lot
of kind of hipsters Cosmopolitan's that
want to go to places like Washington DC
or New York or LA well that's certainly
true but people are voting with their
feet and the majority of people are
leaving places like New York which is
seen a real strong hemorrhaging of
citizens and a tax base displaces like
Texas or New Hampshire or South Dakota
and that's controlling for things like
cost of living and climate so actually a
lot of people moved to those places and
how do you sort of address the the issue
of culture which is a little bit
different than kind of the regulatory or
economic or sort of personal freedom
environment that is people I think many
people who move to New York for instance
would say they go there because they
feel freer there it seems like a place
where they have more choices as opposed
to say moving to New Hampshire where you
know the political environment might be
better but people don't feel like the
world is quite so wide open where does
that phenomenon fit in with your results
well it obviously doesn't fit in with
our index itself which looks really at
the formal components of freedom the
ways in which government regulations and
taxes and and so on can
can affect people's liberty but it's
something that we have to to consider as
well right so people think about freedom
on the margins obviously not every
single person is going to want to live
in South Dakota or New Hampshire so some
people they're going to make that
decision to live in New York including
myself you know because of other reasons
and and and so some of those reasons can
trump freedom but that doesn't mean that
freedom doesn't matter or that it
doesn't matter a lot you know I would
also add that places like New York or
California Massachusetts Illinois these
places aren't as freeze it's made seem
to some of the people living there so
it's not as if there are these deep blue
states that are economically free right
there's a lot less regulation on
business and and so forth but they're
personally free actually a lot of those
deep blue states have nanny state ISM
across the board so if you're a
cosmopolitan living in New York but you
want to eat your favorite kind of
doughnut in a way that a company is
willing to sell it to you well the state
is going to interfere with that there
are trans-fat bans for example in places
like that or just think about the use of
culture if your tax so highly that you
can't actually afford to go to the Med
all the time as a middle-class person
let's say you're not gonna be able to
enjoy that and that even though that met
exists for some people and I would also
add that these places that have economic
diamond is dynamism because of freedom
these are places that are attracting
people and wealth and they're growing
because there's also a correlation
between economic growth and economic
freedom and these places will grow over
time and they'll develop the types of
institutions that are satisfying to
people who want a robust cultural life
all right so in Joel Kotkin for example
has done some work on this and talks
about how well maybe Oklahoma City will
be the next oz now I'm not sure about
that but hey we could imagine these
types of institutions developing because
remember during the you know the British
Empire you know as people have pointed
out the United States wasn't exactly the
center of the cultural universe and and
I think Kotkin has talked about that and
I think that's that's true so so maybe
the the person who goes and flocks to
New York or or LA will in the future be
flocking to
places like Houston what would it take
Jason for you to move to Houston hahaha
well I grew up in Houston and I hated
the climate Houston well I live in Texas
and I one of the reasons I moved there
was because the political culture was
something that was amenable to my tastes
of course I moved to a job as an
academic there aren't a lot of jobs I'm
not a lawyer that can practice law
anywhere but it does factor in the
decision of people that care about
freedom I simply did not apply to any
jobs when I went in the job market in a
place like California because I didn't
want to live in a place like that and so
it does matter to some of us and I would
live in a place like Iowa if the right
kind of job came up or you know as
supposed to say Illinois in which you
know making a middle-class salary I'm
not sure it would stretch as far or that
I would want to have all the nanny state
ISM of a lot of these places like
Illinois or New York but people are
going to have different views and that's
one of the reasons why we actually for
the index on our website at wrc.org we
actually have a tool where you can plug
in some of your own views about freedom
into the rankings and shift the rankings
based on what you think it matters so
we're pretty pluralistic about our
approach in that sense so actually that
sort of brings up this other question
which is there's you're capturing the
variety between states but how much does
that matter in a world where the federal
government is so powerful and so much
more overwhelmingly relevant to people's
experience of freedom and and how
politically or personally or
economically free they are does state
variation yeah does it matter
enough does it matter enough to
influence people's decision-making about
something so big as where they live I
think it matters a great deal people I
think underestimate the extent to which
states have autonomy still areas like
education that's still primarily a state
and local responsibility and I think
that's an extremely important area of
policy right if we who favor Liberty
want to influence the next generation
that's
probably the first area that we should
we should look at reforming one way to
to measure the impact of the federal
government versus the states is to look
at indicators of tax decentralization so
how decentralized our tax collections in
the US so what we see is that that's
decline some over time but still state
and local governments collect somewhere
between 35 and 40 percent of total
government taxes so that implies yeah
that the the federal government is
bigger and more important in a fiscal
sense than the states and localities but
doesn't completely overwhelm them so
states are still really important thank
you very much gentlemen
for reason TV I'm Katherine Maggie ward